tras una cancelación por la pandemia y
una edición sin turismo la marcha del
orgullo en tel aviv regresó con todo su
poderío conocida como la capital el eje
20 y más de medio oriente a esta ciudad
llegan cientos de miles de personas para
celebrar su identidad pero sobre todo
reivindicar el pleno ejercicio de sus
derechos
la mayor parte de israel no es muy
progresista por eso cuando tenemos estas
oportunidades de reunirnos celebrar
quiénes somos y los derechos que tenemos
aquí es hermoso amics beer phone pesa el
sol el contacto y el festejo de la vivi
sus regiones donde más denuncias de
agresiones se producen mientras que en
el resto de israel de 2020 a 2.021 hubo
un incremento del 10 por ciento de estas
violencias por el fbi fobia una
situación que se enmarca en un medio
oriente que es mucho peor con países
como irán yemen o arabia saudita en los
que se condena con la muerte es el
homosexual
[Música]
muchas mujeres trans son asesinadas cada
año en israelí nadie habla realmente
sobre eso si bien el matrimonio
igualitario o la adopción homosexual son
importantes creo que tenemos que poner
los derechos trans primero porque los
derechos que necesitan son mucho más
básicos necesitan el derecho a tener un
apartamento y entablar relaciones y
trabajar sin que se les pregunte
constantemente su género y sin sufrir
micro agresión directamente violencia
por un cambio de ruta por obras públicas
este año el desfile no tendrá como
última postal las orillas del
mediterráneo pero supone el relevo al
resto de marchas del orgullo en europa